说句难听点的话，
就你这种心态，
你去干工作都是对人家老板的一种侮辱，
我说话难听一点对吧，
是25岁，
然后未婚未育嘛，
然后你教育背景大概是本科财政那，
然后我是二三届毕业的，
考了半年多研究生没有考上，
去年是在一家电商公司做后端的一个那个运营，
但是我感觉他就极大的占用了我个人的时间，
我不知道嗯，
有没有工作的人能明白，
就是你这份工作，
可能说你的预期，
我来说我是想考编制或者考公，
我感觉就是这个工作，
他真的就是让我没有很大的精力去做这些事情，
主要是他很消耗我的精神，
因为我们是上六天，
然后休一天嘛，
目前是我已经辞职了，
我其实做这个决定我觉得我还挺勇敢的，
但是就我比较迷茫的是我未来的一个职业选择的问题，
因为我本身呢，
我是属于我父母，
可能也不像，
就是他们后面能给我什么支持，
他们就属于那种传统的很忠式的父母的一个情况，
他们就是那种，
嗯，
你反正以后也要嫁出去啊，
你怎么弄就看你自己，
然后我相对来说，
嗯，
思路也比较理性一点，
就是我现在遇到的问题是我知道可能说考公，
因为说可能在。
过几年步入家庭什么，
我不想让我自己就是这个，
比如生孩子嘛，
就无论干什么，
你可能有一年的空档期，
我觉得这样太被动了，
我想给我后面就是稳妥一点，
我觉得编制对我来说是相对稳定的，
但目前就是我的情况，
我知道大家考编制肯定要付出同等时间的努力啊，
我如果说去干一份当下说能够说工资高一点，
就是说是其他的工作，
那我肯定说这个时间段内我自己没办法兼顾的，
我其实实点纠结，
我不知道怎么选，
然后我未来是因为我之前学的是财经类，
但是大学说实话，
我感觉我运用到实际可能也等于从零开始学，
我嗯，
不害怕，
就尝试自己新的东西，
因为我觉得我的学习能力还是可以的，
但是真的就是我很清楚的一点就是我如果选财务，
我就基本上一个月，
可能一开始在西安吧，
这边，
然后工资可能就是那种，
就是不想因为内行不知道找那种代理记账不太靠谱，
就是学内账的话肯定工资低，
然后嗯，
一开始就是需要自己付出很多相关的那种努力和学习嘛，
然后我对着我职业这方面的规划也大概清晰，
然后另外一个就是嗯，
不知道怎么选，
我如果说是直接考公的话，
那肯定就不能说对，
不能进入。
啊，
月儿，
这个我也知道，
所以我现在就很迷茫，
我不知道该怎么选的一个问题，
因为我不确定说我如果去当一个前台，
全力的备考考编的话，
这两年我的一个会不会停滞，
这个情况父母是干啥的，
他们就是普通的工人嘛，
乌龙啊这些的家里有几个兄弟姊妹呢？
如我是小的，
我姐姐已经结婚了，
嗯，
就是父母能支撑你，
能支持你全职的考编吗？
他们需要我自己去承担这个生活费用，
你有真诚的跟他们聊过吗？
聊过说你的理想的工作是考上编制，
但是现在，
嗯，
由于这个大环境的原因啊，
你考编制这个事情也挺难的，
所以你要全力以赴，
背水一战，
你需要父母的支持去考上这个编制，
你有跟父母去认真聊过这个话题吗？
不要说在心里面去设想前台险一点的去考编制，
但是我真的不知道我能不能考上，
说就是想到一点是我如果这样做了的话，
就是这两年我其实我的一个职业技能就是能任何提高，
说的话啊，
就是说如果你自己分析了你的性格更适合进入体制内，
更适合进入编制内，
而且你也是本科毕业，
有这个资格去考这个编制，
你本人也有这个意愿去考这个编制，
那在这种情况下的话。
你就应该动用你现在能动用的所有支撑你的资源去干这个事儿，
你别一方面想着要考编制，
另一方面又觉得我问爸妈要钱挺没面子的，
我都已经毕业了啊，
我是不是又一边又工作又挣着这个钱，
干着一份自己又不喜欢的工作，
我说句难听点的话，
就你这种心态，
你去干工作都是对人家老板的一种侮辱，
人家老板请你来不是让你三心二意对吧？
老板请你来是要创造价值的，
老板请你来干活是要给公司挣钱的，
就你这种状态去给老板干活的话，
都是老板的倒霉，
就这意思啊，
我说话难听一点，
对不起，
你这个状态就是你确定，
哎，
我就适合进入体制内，
我不适合给老板打工，
我不适合在民营企业工作，
我也对吧，
没有这个竞争的意识，
我就想进入体制内，
安安稳稳的这辈子啊，
我就过个平凡的日子，
我就想过这样的生活，
你就朝着这个方向去，
在这个过程当中用你一切可以动用的资源，
父母如果愿意借钱给你，
就借钱给你，
父母不愿意借钱给你，
姐姐愿不愿意借钱给你，
一年你的生活费是多少钱，
你自己算吧，
算吧，
到底是需要3万也好，
是需要万也好，
对吧，
你需要多少钱，
你把这个成本放在这儿，
你挣钱了之后，
你是能还得了这个钱的呀，
你考一年，
考两年还是考三年，
如果你考三年顶槛了十万块钱，
你的生活成本吗？
因为你光考试，
你又不用参加各种。
这样的人际交往，
你又不用各种人情往来，
你又不用各种各样的那个去去炫富啊，
去旅游啊什么的，
你就是考试嘛，
你就是解决你的生存问题嘛，
一天几个外卖的问题嘛，
对不对？
嗯，
说到这儿啊，
还有啥问题没有，
这很简单，
最基本上是这个问题吧，
我就是不知道自己怎么选，
因为我知道我父母可能说或者是我自己，
或者说一方面是我的家人，
可能大家看到就是自己的那一面啊，
比较的可能主观一些，
我想就是说你能不能就是站在整个角度客观一点，
我很怕会选错，
实话说啊，
因为我毕竟跟你接触的少呀，
咱俩没有在一起共同生活过，
没有在一起深度的去聊过天，
你让我这么一个外人去，
呃，
指导你选择你的人生方向，
这件事情啊，
我感觉我要是说错了，
我怕误导你，
但是凭借我们两个人现在这个仅有的10分钟的这个接触的话，
我感觉你对自己的判断是差不多的，
你可能是更适合一个稳定的安稳的这样一个工作环境，
可能是比较适合一点啊，
嗯，
我想呢，
就是就是如果说在家这边可能是相对说找一个闲一点的前台嘛，
然后就这样做，
但是哎，
就是大环境是这个样子，
反正我刚才那个话说的也已经很明白了，
你要做什么事情，
你就一。
做气破釜沉舟，
你就去干这件事情，
你别一方面又要干个前台，
另一方面对吧，
前途又很渺茫，
又考试，
到时候考试又没考好，
前台工作也没干好，
到时候你像你这样的女孩子上了社会上的话，
特别容易被上当受骗，
特别容易被人家盯上，
他说再有个已婚男的，
像你试好，
给你买个手机了，
给你租个房子了，
你特别容易上当，
那就是全职备考一年，
嗯，
大不了就全职备考一到两年，
给自己两年的时间能考上对吧，
就考上了，
考不上你也就死心了，
嗯，
好好，
我知道了，
好，
嗯，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我说这话我心里面是没有恶意的啊，
我只是，
呃，
客观的评价一下，
就是我二十几岁的时候，
我特别庆幸一点是什么？
在我二十几岁的时候，
我没有钱，
没有前途很渺茫，
没有依靠的时候，
我没有遇到像宋思明这样的男人，
如果我二十几岁的时候，
要是遇到一个像宋思明这样的男人的话，
我也搞不好就走错路了，
对吧，
一辈子可能就蹉跎成那样了。
所以我刚才跟这个妹妹聊天的时候，
我就想到这个问题，
如果说你一方面工作又没有落ing，
另一方面你又去做一个前台，
你在这个过程当中，
但凡有一个已婚的男的向你示好，
说给你一点依靠，
给你租个房子，
或者说对吧，
给你买个手机，
或者说给你还个信用卡，
很容易就。
依靠上别人，
很容易就依赖上别人。